hello everybody my name is Mark blarin
this is Tyler say hi if you're wondering
why we're wearing gloves or wondering
why there's a block of dry ass right in
front of us we're about to do a
challenge shut the [ __ ] so we're gonna
be doing the dry ice popsicle challenge
and if you don't know what that is I
need my phone so here's how's this gonna
work we've got an assortment of both
good and bad tasting things that we're
gonna turn into popsicles on this dry
ice we've made a little indentation here
and then I'm gonna enjoy a nice regular
popsicle and get a popsicle stick out of
it before we have to do this horrible
challenge where we have an assortment of
terrifying and horrible and disgusting
elements we've got vegan mayonnaise
tartar sauce
Capote Lake garlic sauce honey mustard
yogurt dressing we got a mountain Dew we
got a coke gatorade protein shake
off-brand sriracha organic Parmesan
vinaigrette which I don't even know if
it's gonna freeze or not we have root
beer blueberry smoothie we have carrot
smoothie we have pure chocolate sauce
lemon in lime that we're gonna mix into
a zesty popsicle so what's gonna happen
is Tyler and I we're gonna have a little
competition something you may know about
we're gonna play rock-paper-scissors for
sole the loser has to generate a random
number 1 through 13 and that' sorts this
being one these being 13 going down one
here's a magical number poppin up then
we'll pour this in this and then we will
eat that with a but first I'll enjoy
this while back
I like this idea okay we've had one bite
that's good enough for us but okay we
got a popsicle stick which is the only
popsicle stick we got because somebody
forgot to get them at the store he's a
liar you forgot it's time it's really
prod I'm totally about that protection
right Rock Paper Scissors shoot yeah so
you have to generate a random number
something Oh 13 so you got a lemon lime
so it's pure lime juice and pure lemon
juice so it can't be that bad
oh my popped my pot before yours liar
no you just oh I gotta see the freezing
around the edges here
look it's freezing zoom in on that yeah
yeah okay bring in the water we're just
gonna every time we get through one
we're gonna put it down below just so
it's out of the way you do we gotta dip
it in the water or else we eat so you
have to yeah we don't want that all
right
it has a big droopy boobers sugar and
there you devil emanate your eyes a
blink so we got a ziploc bag down here
we're gonna put all the liquids in here
and then freeze that at the end here so
all of them mixed together and we both
have to say goodbye yes stop
procrastinating and let's get to this
could be good it could be good too yeah
it's something that's not necessarily
super liquidy actually there was no so
bad I take a live solid okay it's just
taking a while let me do it a little bit
sludge but that's okay
oh and a hair oh that's lovely I'm glad
people had pests there all right ready
[Music]
not fighting that one it's not bad but a
straw well that one was bad yeah geez
you're too happy about my misery okay so
I'm gonna drop it down to 11 so now
that's one two three okay good I like
tartar sauce it definitely smells more
like mayonnaise but it's not bad
maybe there's just like a cool / yeah
just sabzi for all right I got it just
is just a few dollops just a few dal PO
hope that's chunky oh that's nice and
chunky all right I'm gonna get a mini
popsicle going on here because
[Music]
that's so I'm gonna I'm gonna flip this
so to the other side gets a little
toshio on you want to even toast okay
now let's go warming up it just tastes
like tartar sauce back first man my
mouth put simply reveal horrible signals
ago that was gone I feel like you're
backwards because I have a gloved hand
on top oh well I can't my left hand roll
back the tape see I didn't okay we're
down to 10 now so that's one yes
anything there we go ten oh the
chocolate delicious fantastic make a
bigger popsicle I want some of them
bigger old gods drooping don't watch it
that much
10 days ago as I thought it'd be miss
Chalkley majagual hmm
I think it's that off-brand yeah it's
not her she's brand this was not
sponsored by curry this is not about to
buy anything [ __ ] Allah okay there get a
little droop alright let's do this again
crap brand sriracha - yeah mark salt
here squirt away
squirt it all in there splat it all
around just go do a tiny pop you gotta
cover the cover the stick at least even
the tiniest popsicles ever really when
you have to eat something gross pretties
fries fries sriracha shot dog you are
not gonna like it you're not gonna like
it no don't mind me oh it looks like it
good
it probably tastes like a tongue that's
a good popsicle now that's a bunch of
stuff that's the good stuff that's a
good stuff well how does it taste
Cossack tester like sriracha it's very
gooey once it's nice
this is not part of the deal we all the
- there's no point being happy when you
get bad what if I get a good one you're
not having any of it
you have the chocolate shut off that
good yeah dude you're not gonna win this
fight man Bill Nye the Science Guy Bill
Nye the Science Guy look at that man
that's probably not that bad it's hard
to pick up all right
go forward yeah we're gonna we need a
little separation here because then
there's no risk there's no risk reward
if I keep eating it so no
[Music]
oh it's blueberry get away from the
stupid joke that the beautiful it smells
good
oh yeah oh that's gonna be delicious
that's gonna be one with you so in order
to conserve some time we're gonna do
rock-paper-scissors for the next one
while this one is still things because
we got two channels here until this one
disappears but we got enough time for
one more thing so we're gonna do this
don't lose
[Music]
we will be the one be the one to suffer
dry my spots
find out next on Dragon Ball Z